more than 500 people were injured in
sunday's massacre about 1/4 of them are
still hospitalized
Kristen Babic was wounded as the crowd
of 22,000 people began running in terror
after being shot in the back and nearly
becoming paralyzed
Kristen Babic says she's just thankful
to have survived
she told us Sunday night's show began
like any other concert
I couldn't believe at the time that was
a gun and I didn't want to disbelief is
how Kristen Babic describes the moment
she heard the first spray of gunfire on
Sunday there was even some people who
were yelling don't worry you don't worry
it's nothing second time came around
more people started to realize what it
was and after the third time we knew a
bullet struck the 24 year old in the
back coming very close to her spine your
friend said it was almost like he felt
like a water balloon hit you I said that
because after I was hit I felt it's like
a splatter I was like oh maybe someone
threw their drink or maybe someone's
just being silly
I don't know this blood that you felt
yes but soon after that did you realize
you've been shot started running towards
the back and I realized I couldn't start
couldn't breathe bleeding and fighting
for air Babbitt continued running
alongside her friend Joseph of tsuneo we
made our way to offense because the
other exits were too full and there were
people on the other side helping people
get over and someone caught me and I was
so scared and they even get the biggest
hug and they told me everything's gonna
be okay
Babic was rushed by ambulance to
University Medical Center with broken
ribs and a collapsed lung now in her
third year of law school at the
University of Florida
she had one question for the doctor
gonna be okay all I want to do is
graduate possible when she told me the
bullet was in my spine
all right close to it then my second
question was am I gonna be paralyzed am
I gonna be able to walk again and she
told me when I woke up after they put
the tube in my chest you're gonna
graduate and you're gonna be able to run
a marathon you're gonna run again I see
you still have the wristband on yes I
haven't cut it off yet I don't know if I
should or not Babic says surviving
Sunday's shooting has renewed her sense
of purpose to become a criminal
prosecutor after she graduates in May as
long as there's no more tubes in my
chest I think I'll be able to walk
across the stage and then you'll be
standing in a courtroom as a criminal
prosecutor that's the plan
I just think about that she says that
she's going to be released from the
hospital once her lung is able to
conflate inflate rather correctly on its
own she also told me about that before
she got into the ambulance and strangers
were trying to help her stop the
bleeding she just kept thinking about
trying to grab her phone she describes
kind of that chaos out there she wanted
to grab her phone so she could call her
mom back home her mom was there inside
the room and was also very emotional as
she heard her daughter recount exactly
what happened at that concert Fionna a
special graduation that will be for
Kristen and her family to witness her
walk across that stage and it just
reminds you that as the physical scars
will here heal the emotional scars will
last a lot many stories like it so many
stairs in Las Vegas